[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns in
unserer kleinen süss micro fällt meine
lieben freunde am ende der letzten folge
minecraft mit luca habe ich ja gesagt
dass ich meine items hier noch sortieren
werde das habe ich hier vorne schon
getan dem nassen schwamm werde ich
einfach mal mitnehmen ich habe hier
vorne ein paar sachen reingepackt ich
habe hier oben was reingepackt hier vorn
habe ich was angepackt und jetzt werde
ich mir auch ganz kurz meine kohle
mitnehmen denn das mit dem nassen
schwamm kann ich euch direkt jetzt zu
beginn des videos mal eben zeigen und
das möchte ich euch auch zeigen denn das
werden wir auch gleich mal schön
austesten auf unserem roadtrip das habe
ich nämlich für heute geplant ihr werdet
gleich sehen warum und wohin wir den
ganzen roadtrip umsetzen werden und wo
wir hinfahren werden allerdings wird
schon das hat geklappt ich habe meine
normalen spann behalten mitzubekommen
den kann ich jetzt mit recht irgendwo
hier ins wasser setzen allerdings mache
ich das nicht gefordert denn da passiert
nichts ja gut
perfekt also den
nehmen wir natürlich wieder mit das
werde ich euch jetzt auf dem road trip
zeigen und dass ich auch was ich auch
noch benötige für den roadtrip ist auf
jeden fall diese schaufel und diese
schafe und danke und ich werde mir auch
noch zwei weitere schaufel machen bzw
einfach eine menge holz mitnehmen so
dass ich alles dann unterwegs machen
kann einreise bettchen brauche ich auf
jeden fall auch noch dafür nehme ich mir
mal ganz kurz sich hier die rolle die
wir haben wir haben eine magenta farben
eine volle und wir haben hier oben auch
noch vorne da nehme ich mir einfach drei
weiße wolle denn die werden wirklich mal
wieder lange unterwegs sein und ihr
fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht
nur khabar um sie mit den schülern
sondern unterwegs wo willst du denn hin
ich brauche eine menge sand fragt euch
wahrscheinlich wofür brauchst nur so
viel sand
na ja also wir haben zwei große projekte
für die wir eine menge sand benötigen
erst mal haben wir schon lange keinen
sitz mehr angehört ich bin in ruhestand
gegangen immer idiot also nervt mich
nicht mit deinen belanglosen witz
forderungen amk jetzt weiß ich warum wir
uns so lange kein witz mehr angehört
haben eine riesenbaustelle ist auf jeden
fall die strandvilla und die andere
riesigen baustelle ist der unterwasser
tunnel denn wir brauchen für die
strandvilla für den rand auf jeden fall
noch ein bisschen blöcke weil ich nicht
will dass jeder dieser bruchstein zu
sehen ist ich hab zwar vorne mit gras
angefangen möchte das jetzt allerdings
noch zusammen stein beziehungsweise
glattem sonnenstein umwandeln das werdet
ihr nachher sehen was ich da meine und
für den unterwasser tunnel da hier vorne
stattfinden soll benötigen wir auch eine
menge glas und dementsprechend weil wir
glas benötigen brauchen wir auch dafür
sind deswegen euch denn ganz kurze time
labs wie ich hinten zu unserem wüsten
dorf fahre
[Musik]
so und da sind wir auch hier vorne
wieder in der savanne angekommen und ihr
seht doch schon wenn ich mal nach hinten
gucken die sonne steht schon relativ
tief von daher dürfen wir gar nicht
lange zeit verlieren ich nehme direkt
natürlich mein brötchen hier auch wieder
mit dass wir das nicht nachher irgendwie
verlieren wenn das hier stehen bleibt
ich habe auch vorhin auf dem weg gesehen
dass aus der höhle stehen auch noch zwei
brötchen von mir um mich die sind
irgendwie überall verteilt ich will gar
nicht wissen wieviele punkte ich mir in
diesem projekt ihr schon gekostet habe
die sache ist allerdings dass ich euch
die teils auch jetzt schon mal beendet
habe obwohl wir noch gar nicht direkt in
dem dorf angekommen sind das beginnt ja
erst dort vorne
allerdings sieht ja bereits im titel
eingeblendet dass ich euch den namen
meiner insel verrate denn in der letzten
folge hatte ich ja gesagt dass ich einen
namen eigentlich gerne haben möchte für
mein ganzes projekt hier nicht das ist
ja minecraft mit luca allerdings von der
insel und da hatte ich ja gesagt
irgendwie vielleicht was mexikanisches
irgendwie was spanisches südländisches
was sehr ja also ein bisschen nach dem
ganzen projekt hier auch klingt den
hasse für die immer wieder das spiel
wird sich selber auch mal ein hasen
mitnehmen den sekunden später glaube wir
brauchen dafür löwenzahn
[Musik]
allerdings ist hier dann konnten wir uns
nicht auf die hasen sondern erstmal auf
den namen meiner insel
ich finde es ein bisschen blöd wenn
youtuber ihre zuschauer extrem lange
irgendwie warten lassen auf den namen
und zittern lassen so von wegen ich sage
euch am ende des videos und blabla
ich hab's einfach raus ich habe mich
wirklich für den namen los locos
entschieden
finde ich sehr cool hat sich irgendwie
nach einer griechischen insel im
mittelmeer oder so da die sonne hier nun
allerdings kurz vorm untergehen es werde
ich die zeit ist noch mal ganz kurz eben
nutzen um hier so ein bisschen sand
abzubauen
die bereits zu beginn gesagt benötige
ich den sand und auch den sandstein hier
ist das hier direkt wird das anstellt um
das ist sogar glatter sandstein dass ich
dachte ich müsste den sandstein oder
nachher noch fett im ofen braten
allerdings benötige ich wirklich so
vieles jeder sich werde jetzt alle meine
schaufeln kann auf jeden fall kaputt
machen hierbei weil ich halt das alles
benötige findet unter wasser schon und
für meine strandhaus bilder in der
letzten folge ging es ja ordentlich ab
mit der action im unterwasser tempo 10
monument und zwei transporter singh habe
ich mir gedacht für heute kommen
bisschen vermittler wieder
[Musik]
gerade in der letzten folge ging es ab
und jetzt mit zum lauten ton und was
auch den spaß gemacht hier über kurz und
falls ja warum bin ich selbst schuld
das kannst du dir doch nicht ausdenken
hier in meiner welt die denn die sollte
teleportiert der sich die ganze truppe
glaubt man schon gebucht dass er mir den
sandstein dahinten cloud aber jetzt noch
die 1 auf ich will ihn gar nicht mehr
aus den augen verlieren eigentlich aber
hier geht langsam weg
[Musik]
ok jetzt ist er komplett also ich wollte
sagen hätten in der letzten folge ist
schon ne menge action deswegen müssen
wir heute auf jeden fall wieder ein
bisschen was auf der kette kriegen ich
werde auf jeden fall bei den ganzen
werkzeuge hier jetzt kaputt machen daran
dass ich hier den ganzen sachen
mitnehmen den glatten sandstein ezb von
der euch eine riesige teile geteilt wird
nicht langsam
das hat er sind anteil bleibt dass ich
hier 15 20 minuten was machte und für
euch sein dass ein paar sekunden also
film ab
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde ich habe mein
komplettes inventar voll mit einer menge
glatten sandstein und mit einer menge
sand sand benötige ich wie bereits
gesagt für das glas für den unterwasser
tunnel und den glatten sandstein
benötige ich für die umrandung meiner
stand haus oder die sache ist jetzt auch
dass ich ja hier vorne das schaf ja aber
ich brauche halt die braune wolle für
das gut ist dass im zombie wetter
gewesen die müssen wir auch noch retten
das habe ich noch aufgeschrieben für
heute ich glaube allerdings das schaffen
wir nicht mehr
die sache ist allerdings dass diese
schafe hat braune wolle hat und wir
brauchen halt wirklich ein schaf mit
baumwolle
deswegen ist es meine aufgabe jetzt mir
eben kurz hier aus diesem dorf die tür
setze ich mir einfach hier vorne hin ein
bisschen weizen zu holen das hier ist
noch nicht so ganz gewürzen 210 her egal
wir haben auf jeden fall sechs branche
wolle am start wir benötigen für die kuh
insgesamt 30 so lange habe ich jetzt
auch keine lust zu warten von daher euch
jetzt mal eine ganz kurze time labs wie
ich wieder zurück nach hause fahre
[Musik]
so da sind wir wieder zu hause
angekommen bei unserer kleinen los lukas
inselgruppe ist es ja mehr oder weniger
schon hier vorne mit dem leuchtturm der
direkt zeigt hey du bist da möchte hause
hier vorne direkt in unserem portal
schwert mit der zauberinsel doch ganz
hinten mit der strand hause weder die
sie zu mickrig aus von ihr vorne
allerdings werden wir da gleich auch
direkt hingehen und den glatten
sandsteinen sätzen zuvor
seht ihr allerdings schon dass ich hier
unten eine kleine glocke gelernt habe
deswegen werde ich direkt mein brötchen
auch mal hier vorne jetzt so ganz frech
abstellen für unserer villa insel
es ging allerdings natürlich direkt
mitnehmen und gleich rüber zu unserer
boots insel bringen
denn ich habe ja damals für unsere
kirche dort hinten die glocke hier aus
der v insel geklaut deswegen werde ich
diese hier ganz kurz wieder dran
platzieren wenn ich die jetzt leute geht
jeder will allein in seiner bude jedoch
konzentrieren wir uns nun auf die
wichtigen dinge wir haben nämlich die
bräunung wolle die stadt erstmal ganz
großen items beziehungsweise braucht
sich da jetzt gar nicht mehr soviel
sortieren weil meine katze sind wenn da
er voll mit sand war
von daher würde ich auch sagen packen
die hier direkt sand rein da brauchen
wir dann nämlich so viel kohle für hier
vorne auch sieben cholera brauchen wir
glaube ich acht so das gilt den sand
hier komplett durchgebraten kriegen hier
auch exakt acht stück rain und hier den
kompletten sand noch rein und das hier
fühlen wir auch komplett mit sand so
dass wir dann schlussendlich wirklich
schon mal 46 glas haben wir brauchen
insgesamt glaube ich 20 stacks oder so
wir müssen da noch mal auf jeden fall
hin gewähren wir vorne auch noch eine
menge sand jedoch brauche ich jetzt
gerade erst mal keine sand sondern ein
wenig bruchstein hier vorne zwar kontakt
und meinen glatten sandstein den ich ja
dann schlussendlich verbauen muss an
meiner strandhaus wieder da wäre ich
auch direkt jetzt mal hin laufen und ihr
seht doch schon ich habe immer noch den
schwammen der hand die sache ist
allerdings dass ich auch noch das brot
hier vorne habe dann dass ich das
deswegen dann auch direkt mal ganz gut
zeigen kann das wollte ich zwar
eigentlich hinten im wüsten dorf machen
allerdings dachte ich mir da wir ja
demnächst noch mal hinfahren müssen und
so weiter und so fort das ist vielleicht
ungeil wenn dann der plus irgendwie gar
kein wasser mehr hat weil der schwamm
dann irgendwie saß der
wegen wollte ich das jetzt die vorne
machen zwischen unserer kleinen früheren
baum insel hier haben wir immer bäume
gepflanzt um uns holz zu holen so dass
ich habe so dass wir den delfinen ist es
viele paare haben wieder fest im boot
hallo ich hier als einer von den beiden
clipper das hier ist nicht flipper der
andere da vorne das könnte eventuell
film soll jetzt allerdings gerade
respekt ist jedoch die flipper will stay
das ist es kann auch nicht sagen dass
ich hier nie nie wieder gefunden haben
oder so noch einmal ganz kurz in die
partie aber es ist auch nicht flipper
naja gut also ich selbst mein brötchen
hin und fahre mal ganz kurz nach vorne
denn ich wollte euch jetzt zeigen was es
mit dem schwamm auf sich hat
wahrscheinlich brauche ich ja gar nicht
zeigen weil die meisten von euch mir ja
immer tipps geben wenn diese minecraft
projekt deswegen der hut ist die
wahrscheinlich schon längst bescheid
allerdings wenn ich den jetzt mal vorne
hingesetzt und dann können wir das ganze
einfach mal testen fx sehr gespannt
drauf hab noch nie so eine art schwamm
so richtig benutzt ihr in diesem projekt
von daher setze ich ihn jetzt mal
einfach nicht hier vorne hin und ihr
seht schon ich kann das war's ich dachte
jetzt das unter wasser das man kurz
sieht das ganze wasser verschwindet aber
es war ja nur ein blog weit oder so ist
aber auch egal wir müssen demnächst auf
jeden fall noch mal rüber zum ozean
monument daher dort wirklich noch eine
menge auf uns gewartet hat einmal
behauptet vorne mit unserem ein card ab
wer haut nach vorne
balu okay mach ich habe mich schon
gefragt wobei es aber dann ist er
anscheinend die ganze zeit am rumfahren
mit diesem komischen mein karte da
hatten wir auch schon alle möglichen
leute drin sitzen wie haben dadurch die
schweine mit rüber geholt wir haben da
ändern schon drin entdeckt das ist ja
crazy dass die alle damit fahren aber
gut ihr seht schon ich brauche hier
fordert die bruchsteine ab denn hier
überall kommt glatter sandstein hin die
sache ist eher fraglich ist
wahrscheinlich das ist eine strandvilla
warum den sandstein und kein normaler
sand bei sand musste ich halt steigende
darunter setzen und das sieht man halt
von außen weil das ja hier im wasser ist
und nicht irgendwo in der erde
und da ist halt auch die sache dass ich
mir dann gedacht habe dass ich das bei
männern villiger inseln hinten
eigentlich auch noch machen könnte und
wir damit quasi dann so ein bisschen so
den strand so ein bisschen darstellen
können von euch eine ganz kurze time
netz wir fordern dass mit dem glatten
starten sandstein hier eben mache
[Musik]
so freunde ich habe jetzt hier vorne so
ein bisschen den sandsteinen umgesetzt
bzw den glatten sandstein
es sieht wirklich genauso aus wie sand
finde ich hier vorne um die kurve um
hier habe ich jetzt auch mal dinge revel
abgebaut da habe ich jetzt glatten
quartz hingesetzt die sache ist
allerdings dass wir hierfür noch ein
bisschen gefehlt hat da müssen wir
demnächst auf jeden fall in die hölle
gehen und wie ich das ganze hier vorne
machen werde weiß ich auch noch nicht so
richtig ich werde jetzt erstmal mit
glatten sandstein so ein bisschen was
drumherum bauen als wäre das wirklich
irgendwie sonne kleine sandverwehungen
oder irgendwie so in die richtung und
das jetzt erst mal so ein bisschen
aussieht sieht jetzt zwar nicht gut aus
aber dass wir zumindest sehen ok
dahinter ist was die vorne kommt auch
noch dass links hoch also da müssen uns
was überlegen hier vorne sieht das so
aus sie konnten auch noch der pool hin
und so weiter und so fort ich kann jetzt
mal ganz kurzem ein bettchen nehm ich
hier kurz schlafen legen es ist wirklich
geisteskrank also diese strand aus
wieder wenn die endlich mal fertig sein
wird das wird wirklich heftig aber das
ist ja irgendwie schon so dass running
projekt in diesem projekt hier was ich
auch noch gemacht habe war dass ich hier
vorne bzw
habe ich nicht gemacht aber das wollte
ich jetzt noch eben machen da habe ich
den trocken beton hingebaut damit ich
damit hoch gehen konnte
den habe ich vergessen abzubauen in
einer der letzten folgen deswegen werde
ich das jetzt auch mal eben ganz normal
eben machen den mitnehmen habe ich alles
ja ich hab alles und jetzt werde ich
noch eine allerletzte sache gab es kurz
machen im heutigen video ich nehme schon
wieder seit einer stunde auf ich glaube
das heutige video sich allzu lang und
auch nicht allzu spannend allerdings wie
bereits mehrfach gesagt in diesem
projekt wir brauchen halt ab und zu
solche folgen wie letzte wo wir eine
menge action hatten in dem unterwasser
tempel und dann braucht er allerdings
auch wieder solche folgen
ein bisschen entspannen da sind wo wir
müssen das schaffen wo wir uns ein
bisschen in unserem kleinen kümmern
können und deswegen habe ich das wir
haben mir für heute vorgenommen das habe
ich ganz gut umsetzen können die sache
essen allerdings dass ich noch eine
kleine sache machen wollte dafür packt
erstmal kontrakt um hier rein
die flintstones habe ich hier drin dem
nassen schwamm kann ich mal ganz kurz
noch mal zurück in den ofen packen denn
da muss ich hin denn ich benötige nun
mein glas ich möchte mir dass nämlich zu
beginn jetzt nochmal einmal ganz kurz
schon mal veranschaulichen mit dem
tunnel also zu beginn nicht erfolge
sondern zu mit denen der tunnelarbeiten
die werte haben werden und dann werde
ich mir auch direkt schon mal ein
bisschen glas mitnehmen so dass ich dann
schon mal schauen wie ich das alles
vorbereiten werde ich hab ja sogar echt
eine menge glas und ich benötige auch
noch eine menge bruchsteinen denn damit
werden wir schlussendlich super ich bin
mensch gut versorgt ich möchte ganz kurz
mal eben schauen wie ich das ganze
machen werde dafür brauche ich mich auch
die antriebs schienen und redstone
verkenne beziehungsweise davon habe ich
jetzt gerade gar keine
deswegen habe ich hier welche drin
deswegen machen wir jetzt erstmal ganz
kurz ohne redstone fackeln ich möchte
ganz kurz schauen in wie das wird mit
dem unterwasser tunnel ich weiß nicht ob
alle hier vorne lobenfeld ich glaube der
sitzt hinten fest an der ecke allerdings
möchte ich ja nicht den kompletten
tunnel unter wasser bauen sondern nur
eine stelle sodass sich dort dann auch
immer mit dem ball drüber fahren kann
denn es gab schon auf die situation dass
ich irgendwelche vorne los gefallen wenn
hier hinten lang und dann dort vorne
aussteigen muss darüber gehen muss dann
wieder einsteigen musste so was hab ich
nicht mehr so richtig bock deswegen
würde ich sagen da das ja hier schon
losgeht mit dem korallenriff machen wir
auch hier direkt den pudel hin
dann müssen wir gucken wie wir das dann
quasi mit der strandhaus bilder machen
oder wir machen den tunnel halt erst ab
hier vorne so dass wir hier dann quasi
seinen kleinen halt machen und dann
können wir hier quasi aussteigen für die
strandhaus villa unter anderem hier die
korallen ich weiß allerdings auch nicht
wie weit das geht doch das geht auf
jeden fall ein bisschen der soll ja auch
nicht komplett über die ganze entfernung
angehen deswegen werde ich direkt mal so
machen dass es ab hier runter gehen soll
also ab hier geht es quasi weg dann
brauche ich diese blöcke jetzt einfach
mal direkt ab dann kann ich mir auch die
redstone fackel hier direkt mitnehmen um
zu gucken mich dass zum unterwasser
machen werde hier den bruchstellen weg
und hier den links weg die teile kommt
mit dauer nach oben
dann werden wir es jetzt zu machen dass
wir hier quasi die strecke runter lassen
werden da es halt die frage wie weit ich
das ganze machen werde
also wie weit wir quasi runtergehen
werden ich möchte das schon so ein
bisschen durchfahren also ich glaube
diese höhe sollte es schon sein
dann können wir nämlich entspannt ein
bisschen drüber fahren wir immer ganz
kurz nach oben hier die luft einatmen
kennt man auch unter wasser atmen holen
können aus meinem fach allerdings wollte
ich das jetzt einfach mal ganz kurz
machen jetzt platz ihre hier vorne
bruchsteine und darauf die glasteile und
der bruchstein hier an der seite kommt
nachher weg bzw
da kann ich theoretisch auch hoch
steigen lassen und obendrauf kommt
selbstverständlich auch nochmal glas
also so dann quasi und so soll das ganze
dann losgehen ich weiß nicht was hier da
passe ich glaube ich nicht durch
deswegen müssen wir hier glaube ich
einen blog sogar höher geht hier vorne
und bump dann haben wir hier quasi
unseren tunnel drin wir können auch hier
vorne das ganze buch stadt machen dann
sieht es glaub ich ein bisschen
abgeschnittener aus haben wir hier
bruchstein und hier oben bruchstein dann
geht sie quasi wieder einen runter hier
vorne einen bruchstein hin und hier und
dann wieder mit dem glas blöcken hier
nach oben
drei stück hier dann wieder bruch
steinbruch stein und glas ich baue das
war mal ganz kurz also so sieht das
ganze jetzt aus dass jetzt quasi unser
unterwassertunnel die sache ist jetzt
allerdings dass wir hier eine menge
wasser drin haben und jetzt könnten wir
eigentlich perfekt unseren schwamm
benutzen
allerdings habe ich den gerade nicht
dabei deswegen werde ich jetzt erstmal
ganz kurz die erde für benutzen und die
hier vorne hin setzen so dass wir uns
hier vorne ein bisschen das wasser vom
leib halten star zac jetzt muss ich nur
aufpassen dass sich gleich hier
vernünftig rauskomme und wieder genügend
luft kriege und jetzt können wir hier
die herde wieder abbauen sehen dass sich
hier vorne ein bisschen verkackt habe
mit dem wasser das heißt hier nochmal
kurz am hochstein hin sagt hier die erde
abbauen und hier unten wird das gleich
wieder wasser hingegen kommen weil ich
habe hier keine erde mehr hatte
das werde ich jetzt allerdings mal ganz
kurz von elternseite machen hier vorne
ist ein tintenfisch gefangen so einmal
kurz runter schwimme hier vorne müssen
wir da noch eher dahin platzieren so
kamen die erde genommen und hier vorne
gesagt gesagt sagt
zack zack zack zack zack jetzt von oben
immer direkt wieder rein so dass wir
vernünftig luft bekommen und die erde
wieder abbauen und dann müssten wir
eigentlich zumindest schon mal bis zu
dem wasser level das alles gedribbelt
haben mit dem wasser so dass hier alles
staubtrocken drin ist und wir die
schienen platzieren können das wollen
wir wieder eine menge in die kommentare
geschrieben dass ich ja mit dem neuen
update erschienen unter wasser setzen
kann
allerdings ist das ja der glastunnel so
dass man links nicht raus gucken kann
und ich fand so ein bisschen witzlos
wenn ich das jetzt einfach so easy
mitmachen würde und sagen gewicht update
auf die neueste version und dann geht es
klar also so soll das gab es hier
wirklich sein dass wir unser glastunnel
klar jetzt gerade sprossen ganz hat den
kopf wenn ich eine hinsetze sodass es
geht nicht die gegner automatisch kaputt
allerdings soll das dann glaube ich auf
dauer funktionieren die sache ist wenn
ich jetzt diesen dienst nutzen will die
sache ist was ist wenn bald zurückkommen
will aber der trinkt dann nicht oder in
der hinten ins wasser fertig hätte auf
jeden fall mein block fortsetzen so dass
er bald zurückkommt dass er da nicht
irgendwie aufgrund meiner dummen
unvollendeten baustelle da vorne dass er
da nicht irgendwie ins wasser fällt oder
dann ertrinkt um gottes willen es soll
dann auf jeden fall so aussehen also
signal ist ein bisschen schöner gemacht
das ist jetzt allerdings erst mal der
erste entwurf und da kann ich quasi hier
so runter fahren und das ist jetzt nicht
sein
ja das ist ausbaufähig wenn ihr tipps
für diesen unterwassertunnel meine
lieben freunde und bitte nicht den tipp
in die kommentare schreiben einfach
updaten
dann schreibt mir bitte gern unter die
kommentare beim befindet sich nicht
irgendwo da ganz hinten die müssen wir
auf jeden fall zu beginn der nächsten
episode holen die sonne gebleichten der
unterhielt sich die strandhaus gedacht
schon echt ein bisschen geiler aus da
hinten mit den fackeln das wird
natürlich alles noch allerdings meine
lieben freunde wie bereits gesagt an der
stelle endlich das heutige video
schreibt mich ein tipp zonen in die
kommentare was soll ich in der nächsten
folge machen schreibt sie auch uns in
die kommentare und wenn es euch gefallen
hat das natürlich gern selbst
wahrscheinlich einen daumen hoch und ein
video hinter abonniert main kanal und
legt auf die lok ein teil der schulzeit
und das neue video übermorgen um 2
und ich verpassen wollt wir sehen uns
auf euch lieb
[Musik]